[Music]
when I should throw in the towel with my
marriage you know a lot of years of
struggles and yelling and fighting and
smashing things you are her mostly me my
wife specifically is a trigger for that
every time you smash something every
time you yell that's the choice you're
[Music]
making what up this is John with the Dr
John deloney
show and I don't know when you're
listening to this but where we're
recording this here in Nashville it is
snow
apocalypse I think the the temperature
outside is one I think it's one degrees
outside maybe zero and there's snow and
we all crawled and scratched our way
into the studio so we could hang out
with you today so glad that you're here
we're talking mental health marriage um
emotional health your physical health
whatever you got going on in your life
keep kids schools all of it if you want
to be on the show it's real people going
through real stuff in their lives if you
want to be on the show give me a buzz at
33291 or go to John
delone.org hit that subscribe button if
you can roll over to YouTube and just
say all right I'll subscribe to this
thing just hit subscribe it makes such a
big difference for everybody getting
access to the show many people who don't
even know the show exists so thank you
so much for helping us out let's go out
to Orlando Florida and talk to Lance in
the pants what's up
Lance hey how's it going good man what's
up not much that's literally the first
time I've heard Lance in the pants Oh I
had a buddy named Lance I call him Lance
in the pants for like 20 years it
literally just came out like I think
it's a part of my nervous system now so
Lance in the pants what's up I've heard
it a million times yeah
um so yeah I guess um I guess I'll just
start with kind of the question I gave
you um and probably work backwards from
there um basically just wanting to know
like when I should kind of throw in the
towel with with my marriage um it's just
been uh you know a lot of years of
struggles
and yelling and fighting and smashing
things so you are
of uh mostly me okay um at least when it
comes to the the the breaking things um
that absolutely has listen has nothing
to do with your
marriage zero no I I I understand that
it's something I've been working on for
a while okay um and that's kind of one
of the one of the problems I feel
like my marriage my wife specifically is
a trigger for that it's uh bull crap
dude I don't I don't buy it I don't buy
it she might know how to push your
buttons but every time you smash
something every time you yell that's the
choice you're making or if you can't
make it in that moment you've made the
choice to create a world where y'all
don't talk you don't connect you don't
exercise your body doesn't feel good
you're not sleeping you don't have a job
that you care to be at that where you
feel like you got a purpose and then all
that crap comes home all of those are
choices along the
way right right yeah absolutely I I take
full responsibility for for that okay um
like you said she knows how to push my
buttons and I feel like she does it a
lot um and I've spent probably the last
four or five years tell her you know I
need connection I need when we talk I
need you to stay calm and not get ramped
up um and that part of it hasn't changed
so I'm just that's kind of where I'm at
with with you know when do I say this
isn't going to change and I need to move
on the The Challenge here is by the way
you you quit your marriage whenever you
want to quit I don't think this is a
marriage that is unsalvageable I'll ask
you a few questions in a minute and you
you can just kind of cut to the chase
for us all but um yeah it's tough when
you're somebody who reacts in what I'm
going to I'm going to overuse a word
right and so I'm going to over dramatize
this but not really when you react in a
violent way meaning screaming using your
body you're you're bigger than she is is
my guess you're or maybe taller than her
you smash stuff you get so angry and
then you feel shamed about it you get
you get you're like I'm never going to
do that again I'm going to be cool and
then you come to her and say hey when I
talk to you I need you to be calm I need
you to be cool so that we can have these
discussions and her nervous system
knows no way in hell am I not going to
be fully on guard cuz who knows what
that dude's going to
do right and then that sets her she's
completely on edge you feel her being on
edge you start to get more and more
frustrated she feels it even more and so
what she do she hits you first to create
some space and then you go off and
hitting you first means she pushes your
buttons yeah and so the only way forward
is is there has to be a complete this
thing's got to let me say this the
marriage you had is over the choice you
have is to rebuild one where you're both
in on it and you're going to have to do
more than four years of quote unquote
just working on it you're going to have
to do better than that man and she's
going to have to
decide terrifyingly
so to put herself in a position to have
something smashed over her again to be
screamed at you have you all have little
kids yeah we have two little kids and
that's my biggest concern because the
stuff has happened right in front of
them yeah but man you you you say in one
sentence like I totally own this but on
the other side you're like yeah this
kind of stuff just keeps happening in
front of them it's you you're happening
I don't mean yeah I don't mean it keeps
it it has happened and I don't want it
to happen anymore it's okay so tell me
tell me what happens in those moments
where you can't control
yourself
um because she's not on the phone with
me hey and before we go I'm I'm I'm
harping on you she's not on the phone
and dude I know I've got people in my
life that can just cut me to the
quick they know how to do that right
people I've been in relationship with
for years and years and years and years
and years men and women they can just
say the thing that sends me over the
edge and I know that so I've got some
choic I'll give you the most recent
scenario because that's what kind of
triggered me to call you okay um we were
you know we were outside we had a
campfire uh out in our backyard it was a
great great night you know made s'mores
and all that stuff there was a few
moments throughout the night where like
one of our sons was rolling around on
the ground and my wife was like don't
roll on the ground there's dog poop or
something like that and I was like just
let him roll the ground it's okay you
know let him be a kid and then another
one came up to us and asked for another
s'more and my wife is like No And I was
like just let him have one it's you know
we're having fun just you know Let it go
so she was like she was saying she was
surprised by me being kind of loose
about things which I do tend to be very
tight you know when we're in everyday
stuff I like to keep a regular schedule
it keeps keeping a schedule keeps me on
track as
well um so when the night was over I was
cleaning up stuff outside she went
inside with the kids and I could hear
yelling from outside the house um I
don't remember exactly what happened but
I came inside and my wife is like I'm
losing my cool I need you to take over I
was like fine I'll take over no
problem and then my little one is like
starts to turn the TV on and I'm like
I'm like no it's 10:30 you know we'll go
read a book we're not going to watch TV
she came back out and was like why can't
you watch TV he's just he's got to calm
his brain and I'm like I don't want him
to watch TV it's it's 10:30 and then she
like kind of threw in my face that you
know you've been so loose all night long
and now this and we went back and and it
ended up with me getting angry and
breaking a
chair
um but it's those kinds of things it's
like this battle between us with control
I think well let's let's reverse
engineer this because it's deeper than
control we're going to go backwards
never freaking break anything in your
home again got
it agreed cool are we done with that
crap because that's you acting like a
five-year-old five-year-old smash stuff
yeah adults do not are you done with
that I am yeah I want to be no bull crap
stop walk out the door go get a hotel
don't smash stuff in your
house you're encoding that stuff in your
kid's nervous system
quit you're terrifying your wife
stop and then going back times where
I've do I've I've done the walking out
the door and you know I would say I got
to leave I'll be back and then when I
get back I get guilted by my wife for
leaving and the kids were upset about me
leaving and I'm like well it's one or
the other like either exactly right it's
one or the other I know when I've
exceeded my capacity to act like an
adult I'm gonna step out for a
minute and for the first two three five
10 times your kids are gonna be where
did Daddy go is he coming back and Mom's
Gonna Act Like irrational and be mad and
yelling
but you're going to be practicing
staying calm in a
moment yeah right the adult is running
the house not the child so the the
description you described to me sounds
like dude chill out they're at of fire
he's rolling around the yard so what if
he gets dog poo that's all he's going to
learn what I heard yeah
is a woman who is constantly trying to
please her husband who's got a bunch of
rules and schedules and
regulations and so here's what she's
trying to do a trying to keep the peace
to trying to keep this crazed man calm
and B in her own weird way she's trying
to love you the best you
can and then you switch it and my guess
is that goes against her nature and so
she feels like she's always having to be
the mean parent and then suddenly in
front of the
kids she's the super mean parent and
you're become the cool
parent and then there's another instance
where there's a TV on at 10:30 at night
with a little kid which by the way that
does not calm down any child's brain it
spins it up but then suddenly she's like
oh I want to be the cool parent which is
is that is that an like an like a
childish response yes is that
understandable of
course and here's the deeper problem
y'all haven't had those talks before
they happen youall haven't had like hey
what are we how's our parenting approach
going to be to screen time
how's our parenting approach going to be
to X and Y and Z because my guess is you
said uh keeping a schedule keeps you on
track I don't buy that I think keeping a
schedule keeps you in control I bet your
schedule's pretty rigorous
huh uh it's it's a little crazy yeah
okay so mine is
too but my wife gets up at a different
time than me and my wife actually gets
up and writes for an hour and has a cup
of coffee she has like a little like a
muffiny cookie thing something I I
usually don't ever eat in the morning we
have very different morning
routines why do you subject your family
to
yours I don't I don't try to subject my
family to mine I I'm up at 5: in the
morning I go work out you know and my
wife isn't usually up until around 7
7:30 and she gets our kids ready for
school then I take our younger one to
school
um and that part is all fine with
me
the part of the problem I have with it
is it's not with her it's not consistent
so it's like there'll be times I come in
for at 7 o'clock and she slept through
like three alarm clocks and you know
it's 20 after and I'm having to wake her
up and say hey I'm going to be late
getting our son to school I need you to
get
up so a lot of it feels like parenting
her sometimes and I I get frustrated
with that one thing I told her a couple
months back when we were talking is I
feel like I've been pushing our family
up a hill for the last 10 years and it's
just I'm getting worn
out because I'm constantly trying to
push to
keep things moving
forward you ever asked your wife what
she wanted
I mean we sat down and we've had talks
with like she'll tell me I need I need
um I need romance I need you know and
romance to hers like little notes here
and there or bringing her flowers and um
you know I've done those things not
consistently to my you know if I'm being
honest I'm not real consistent about it
because again our schedule gets crazy
and I just
forget um but it should be you know I've
like started in the last couple months
putting notes in my calendar to remind
me you know on Thursdays pick up flowers
or you know stuff like
that um so we sat down and had to talks
about needs and you know wants and stuff
like
that
I I've told her many times I need
connection from her and connection for
me is like long deep conversations and
she's just like well I I not smart about
those things I can't have those deep
conversations I'm like I just want to
talk I want someone that I can talk and
laugh and have fun with um are you
somebody that every that every
conversation ends up like in
some like a hubman
podcast or every or every conversation
ends up in a Dr AA
podcast I'm I'm a lot like that I'll
admit it so here's deep S I almost
burned out every friend I have over that
crap so two things number one I have a
coach that I pay an exorbitant amount of
money that I meet with on Friday
mornings and we meet for hours you know
we talk about the craziest scientific
theological rabbit holy social
psychology stuff in the world because I
have to have that and when I worked at a
university I was every lunch was like
some Theory some some legal scholar
talking about talking about this with an
anthropologist I mean that was my whole
life for 20 years and I miss
that but your wife is right every
conversation like that feels like she's
not enough for
you and you get frustrated and she feels
her lack of making you
frustrated and so you have to be a
grown-up and say okay I need
this but this isn't the person for that
when I was taking when I was taken when
I was at an MMA gym I needed like that
physical contact well that's not my wife
right she's not going to sit in the
living room and fight me so I had to go
somewhere
else see what I'm
saying yeah I get it I want you to
listen to your language I've been
pushing my family up a
hill my guess is your wife's tired of
getting
pushed yes you have like get you feel
like you have to parent her I also often
not all the time sometimes people are
just immature I don't give a crap they
sleep in through their alarms they're
lazy they just don't
care there's also people who have just
flat given up because they can never do
it right and whenever they try to do it
the way you want to do it it just goes
sideways or you change the rules or you
get mad or you're doing this or what
about
that
is that ringing a bell yeah yeah that
sounds more along the lines for
sure
so do you want to end your marriage and
I don't I don't have a stake in the my
marriage is fine I don't have I don't
have a a a a stake in this I'm just
asking you point blank are you done with
this
marriage I don't want to be no I want
that's not the question I
ask I don't want to have eaten a bagel
for breakfast this morning I bagel this
morning I never do that and I know it's
going to cost me my blood sugar is going
to fall off a cliff here in about 45
minutes I'm asking
you is your marriage over I want to keep
working on it I want to keep working on
it yeah but you also don't want to smash
chairs tell me am I going to work on
this or am I not going to work on
this no I'm gonna keep working on it
okay the path forward I see for you is
and you're not going to like this I feel
like I've said this three or four four
times the last uh several shows and I
haven't I don't think I've ever said
this before up until
now is that you find somebody to watch
your
kids and you blow off your 5:00 a.m.
workout for the next
morning and one night you take your wife
out to dinner
early and you hold both of her hands
across the table or you send your kids
to a babysitter somewhere else's house
and you do it at your house and you take
a knee in front of her and you just say
hey I'm
sorry I've been pushing you up a hill
I've been trying to create this thing in
my head and you and I could go down a
rabbit hole my guess is you're running
from something I don't know what you're
trying to hold together so
firmly or what picture you're trying to
solve for but your attempt to make
everything perfect in your home is
destroying your
home yeah you could probably make a
career out of me there's a lot going on
well it's it here's the thing you're
doing it right
and what I mean by that is my guess is
you went through hell growing up and you
have found a way to solve for that and
that is systems and control and strength
and and and discipline and determination
Fair yeah cool that works on a David
goggin's podcast it does it works in his
real
life doesn't work in
99.9999999% of
marriages
okay yeah so if you want to stay married
you want to keep your family
together tell your wife I'm
sorry I acted like a child when I scream
at you I act like a child when I smash
things that will never ever happen
again I've been trying to force a life
on you I never asked you what you wanted
in this life what you felt like here's
exercise I want you all to explore how
do you want your home to feel when you
walk home home from walk in from work
every day how does your wife want the
house to feel when she opens her eyes up
in the
morning because my guess is that alarm
goes off and her body says don't get
up don't get
up how do you want do you want your kids
to I heard you say that before and just
to like after that fight I did leave for
the for a night I went to a friend's
house and stayed there and when I came
back like I told there was just this
feeling like it was like a 2hour drive
and an hour there I just had this
feeling like a backpack heavy backpack
was just taken off CU that was the day
that was the night I told her or the day
I told her I want a divorce and like I
don't think I really meant that at the
time but it was I just didn't know what
else to say to stop the the fight we
were having the conversation we were
having and so I left for a friend's
house and I just felt this relief that I
haven't felt in a long
time and what do you know about
feelings uh what do you mean by
that feelings are designed to keep you
safe they don't tell the
truth
yeah there's probably a sense of relief
that you didn't smash somebody this time
because that day is coming my friend
when you're going to be leaning over
somebody you love because you think it's
bad now your kids haven't started really
coming after you when they get in first
second third fourth Middle
School my fear is on your trajectory
you're standing over somebody you love
and they're curled up in a fetal
position with their face busted
up because that's where you're
headed yeah that's what I went through
as a kid and I don't want to that so I
need you to hear me say with all
certainty 100%
certainty the thing you are trying to
achieve through radical discipline
through everybody doing everything right
through turning your family into a
military
unit is actually starving your body from
what your body needs because if you got
the crap beat out of you as a kid your
body still wondering as a 5-year-old why
are you hitting me I'm a kid
and that's that ferocious rage that
comes out when you find yourself
smashing a chair after a pretty good
night with your family that's the fifth
that's the 5-year-old that's the fifth
grader still trying to defend
you the difference is your wife's not
throwing punches like your old man
did and until you decide and this dude
this word sucks I hate it I hate it with
all my heart and it's the truth until
you decide to open yourself up to
actually let this woman hurt
you that's the only way she can actually
connect with you that's the only way you
can save your marriage it's called
vulnerability and that's beyond writing
little notes her writing little notes is
proxy that's her begging will you just
think of me one time over your stupid
Calendar please over your workout
program
please that's what she's
asking yeah do I even enter your mind
until you get home or am I just an
employee of yours that you think about
when you walk in and you're looking to
inspect my
performance and does this mean she's
perfect God no no
way but she's not on the
phone the things I can do
you what you need to do is tell your
wife you're sorry and I would list very
specifically how you've hurt her and
it's not and you made me she's not made
you do one damn thing dude she's never
made you smash a chair you did that
she's never once made you raise your
voice you chose that and until you take
full ownership of
that it's going to be this Tit for Tat
thing now you're bigger and louder than
she is you probably have made her parent
a certain
way you've probably made her clean a
certain way now she could always leave
but that's
different so I'd be very specific and
then I would let her know I have signed
up I'm going to see a counselor in my
community to deal with my childhood
abuse the time of running INF flexing is
over I'm going to deal with
it that's the only way you can save your
marriage my friend that's it that's it I
wish there was another way that's
it and I think that relief you
felt was this a an illusion that ah the
responsibilities are gone that's very
very
temporary but I also think that relief
was your body saying oh thank God
because we were holding back from doing
something really
bad and I'm telling you right now you
need to go seek professional help to
deal with that inner rage and for
especially men and women yes but
especially little boys who are
physically
abused from some tough guy
dad or that tough guy mom for that for
that instance that shame will haunt you
and your family forever until you say
I'm
done and I'm done isn't just fluxing
through every hard conversation and
trying not to hit a hole through the
sheetrock I'm done is sitting with a
counselor and saying I'm letting this
crap go I'm not letting that abuse run
my life
anymore I love you man call me anytime
and I'll be honest with you I I'll shoot
it to you
straight I actually think your marriage
can be saved and not only saved but
think it can grow into something pretty
amazing the thing that your body has
been desperately screaming and searching
and running for all these
years but you're going to have to start
over from Square Zero from from from
Step Zero and your wife's can to have to
be Allin too that means both of you are
going to have to be very vulnerable and
that's going to be scary for a while
we'll be right
back you know I'm always talking about
sleep what I don't talk about enough is
the role temperature plays in deep
restorative and Powerful sleep the
problem in my house and I'm sure it's
like yours is that I like it really cold
and my wife likes to sleep on burning
coals and for me to get it cold I have
to crank down the air conditioner often
even in the winter and it's wasteful
expensive and it drives everyone else
Bonkers but the gurus at 8 sleep did it
I'm so excited that eight sleep is
partnering with the Dr John delone show
to take care of our listeners and
ultimately change your marriage and
change your life our friends at eight
sleep have created a fitted sheet with
cooling and heating technology embedded
in them it's called the eight sleep pod
and the Pod cover can easily be added to
your existing mattress like a fitted
sheet for individualized temperature
adjustments down to 55° for people like
me and up to
110° for people like my wife and this is
based on your environment your body
temperature throughout the night and it
cools down or warms up each side of the
bed it learns you and it does all this
automatically and this will improve your
Sleep Quality like you have to
experience to believe the eight sleep
pot also has built-in vibration alarms
that wake you up when it's time
gradually changes the temperature of
your mattress to gently wake you up and
it can even provide sleep and health
reports like heart rate HRV and all
those things you don't have to wear
anything this is the ultimate sleep
experience go to 8sleep.com to read more
learn more I challenge you to go read
about this it's amazing see if you want
to change your sleep and change how you
show up in your life that's EIG G HT SLE
p8 sleep.com
delone or enter promo code delonia
checkout for up to
$400 in savings check them
out all right let's go out to
Detroit man home of the lions that are
just crushing it right now let's talk to
Kayla what's up
Kayla hey how are you good how are
you nervous don't be nervous you're good
you're in good hands what's
up um so I guess my main question was
that I've
recently become an alcoholic and I'm not
quite sure
how it happened or why I
guess I don't know that that's the most
important thing right now no it's not
but
um I know I need to deal with it and I'm
also working on that too what does that
mean um I'm just started recently going
to therapy um I gave my husband all my
cards and stuff so that way I don't have
access to buy it
are you spinning well back back me up
here what happened how how I mean how
did we get
here
um well I
guess it's only been really like strong
for the last six months um but it kind
of I think it started when we moved out
here uh my husband kind of went through
a deep depression phase and I kind of
had to pick up the slck of every
everything in the house and it kind of
just became
overwhelming and after a year of doing
that I slowly started drinking
to make myself feel better and it just
got worse and worse and worse over time
okay um so in your case alcohol works
man because your home life sucked was
really
tough yeah and I know it's not like PC
to say but being married to somebody
who's in a dark depression and can't get
out of bed and you're taking care of
everything do you all have
kids yes we do okay so you're doing
everything everything everything plus
worried about the electric bill plus
worried about things that y'all had not
previously agreed were your part of your
job description
right do you have a history of
alcoholism in your
family um unfortunately yes one of my uh
sisters has died from it my mother has
died from it and Di from was an alcoh
alcoholic
yes so you are playing with
fire yes
yeah and then like I I know that and I
don't want to do it but it's just like
there's something in me that I just
can't like I know I know it's a it's a
demon I
know I promise there's light on the
other side but right now it is scary
scary
scary it is
because you told yourself this would
never happen to you after walking with
your sister's death your mom's death you
you swore up and down and the challenge
here is yes you're drinking and yes
you're scared to death and yes it's like
becoming easier and easier have you had
a drink
today no not not yet okay but right when
you get off this call you will to calm
down because you're nervous
right I'm still gonna love you I'm not
gonna be mad at
you yes okay um
not only is that the case but you swore
to yourself it would never happen to you
and so you've lost trust in
Kayla is that
fair
absolutely so I think we can get to the
why it sounds like your childhood was
hell on Earth
Fair
yes um and then your
body for lack of better terms you've
married your unfinished business
and you married somebody with some
similar mental health challenges and
you're going to solve it and suddenly
you realized I can't solve this and your
body was like ah I got a plan for when
we can't solve a
problem both genetic bad and
behaviorally right you're in it you're
in it up to your
eyeballs
yes there's one plan and one plan only
you got to go scorched Earth
because you're going to
die if I'm you if you're my sister if
you my wife if you were one of my
closest closest
friends I would tell you I don't see a
path forward without you going to an
impatient treatment right now before
this thing gets the train completely
leaves the
station the fact that you haven't drank
this morning before this call that's a
good I'm taking that as a good sign
because you're nervous up until now
right
yes did you drink last night so you
could sleep before
today yes I did
yeah so it's it's it's growing on you
like a dementor right like a shadow
coming up behind
you yeah it does how's your husband
right now can he handle things for for a
for a a few
weeks uh he absolutely could um he has
tried getting me to do impatient
treatment what's your
hesitancy uh I I have very bad anxiety
with not being around my kids okay I
know that he could take care of them as
just leaving them for that amount of
time it's just stresses me out and then
have you heard me talk about
anxiety yes all the
time have you taken that anxiety
test yes and I got red on every every
spot every one of them every single one
all right what's my cornerstone rule
about
anxiety which oh you're
gonna do what oh you're just gonna have
to tell me okay my cornerstone rule or
I'll say I'll I'll I'll say it in nerd
speak okay when you feel anxious about a
thing
and you walk away from that anxiety
meaning I know that if I don't go to
impatient Rehabilitation I am going to
die and my kids will experience what I
experienced when my mom
died the guilt the pain the
hell but your body feels anxious about
leaving your kids because in some ways
you're worried about your husband's
ability to care for them and in some
ways they've become a pacifier to you
there is Xanax for
you they one glimpse of light in a
pretty dark World
Fair yes yes so it's less about are they
going to be okay and it's more about are
you going to be
okay and when you feel that anxiety you
run and you hug those kids and here's
what happens your body actually
reinforces the anxiety it makes it
stronger because it got what it wanted
it
worked and what it wants is for you not
to get any further away from the light
as possible and those two little kids
are all the light you
got and my cornerstone Rule and it's not
my rule it's Neuroscience the only way
to get those that anxiety to stop is to
head directly into
it you anxious about leaving your kids
for 30 days I'm going to Sprint towards
that you anxious about um how your
husband's going to be able to handle it
we're going to sit down and we're going
to make a plan are you anxious about
waking up dead
like your mom like your sister like your
aunt I'm going to make a committed plan
that never happens to me you see what I
mean this is changing your posture this
is you standing up tall for the first
time in your life putting your chin up
and your shoulders back and saying I'm
heading right into this and then you
realize I can't walk into this by myself
it's too scary I've been there I
know and you got a husband who's saying
hey will you go get this taken care of
because I don't want to bury
you you got two little kids looking at
you
you've got the ghosts of your mom saying
honey take care of this take care of
this take care of
this how does that all
sound besides really really
scary
um I don't even know it's just
SC it's just scary it is um
that and I know I need to do it
okay let this be the
day and
listen your body's going to Crave this
one thing if you've heard me talk about
anything read anything I've written
always I'm talking about homeostasis
your body's going to want to go back to
what it
knows it knows alcohol it knows chaos it
knows
anxiousness it knows somebody who said
he was going to love you ends up in a
really dark place it's what your body
knows and so rehab for you hey it's
going to be not drinking right but
bigger than that it's going to be you
learning a new way to
live and that sounds scary but doesn't
that sound freaking
amazing it does it
does imagine walking in your front
door and you just start laughing when
you get home
and your knucklehead kids come running
up to you and your husband's on the
couch and you're like oh
God but the heat is
on and your husband's hung up Christmas
lights somewhere in the house and who
knows whatever whatever fantasy you have
in your
head I want you to know you can build
that you can't do any of it if you're
drinking is it unfair that you got this
deck of cards yeah yeah it is I didn't
get that deck of
cards I eat when I'm stressed I don't
drink but that's the card you got and
that's the card you got to deal
with will you make that call
today yes do you promise I do okay I'm
going to have Kelly put a note on the
calendar in 30 days we're going to reach
back out to
you okay
okay this is going to be absolute hell
okay anyone who tells you otherwise is
lying to you
and the light and peace on the other
side of this thing is going to be
something you have never experienced
before in your life and you have an
entire country of people behind you on
this one but by the way we don't matter
the person who matters is your husband
people who matter your kids person that
matters is the woman standing in the
mirror so proud of you Caleb
tonight after you make that call and say
I'm ready to go actually first tell your
husband then tell U make the call and I
want you to shoot us an email and just
say hey I'm checking in tomorrow morning
at whatever time at whatever location
whatever impatient treatment and we'll
send you something nice over there I'm
really really proud of you
cayb today is the first day of the rest
of your
life man I'm proud of you we'll be right
back New Year's is my favorite time of
the year and this year I'm committed to
finally establishing an ongoing
journaling routine developing a
consistent and guided daily prayer
practice as well as getting back to
meditating and doing my coherence
breathing exercises on a daily basis one
place where I can do all of this in the
same location is with my favorite app in
the world hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app on planet Earth it has
over 10,000 audio guided prayers
meditations and music I use the guided
prayers and scripture readings from for
my personal development I listen to the
LOI beats while I Journal I'm a sucker
for good Loi and occasionally when
things get sideways I return to the app
in the afternoon for peace throughout
the day whether you're a person of
Christian faith who is looking to renew
your way of living or you're curious
about all this Faith talk and you just
want to explore hallow is for you for
listeners of the Dr John deloney show
you get three free months of hallow all
10,000 plus prayers meditations music
the lecture series and more all of it by
going to hall.com
dealone that's three free months of the
app at hall.com
dealone all right we're back let's go
across the big pond and talk to Sophie
in London what's up
Sophie Hi there Dr John thank you so
much for speaking with me of course
thanks for calling in how you doing I'm
doing great it's freezing here but the
sun is shining so that's great how about
you it's freezing here and it's pitch
dark
yeah the land of sadness what's up no
sunshine here well I'll try to be I'll
try to be all the sunshine you need for
today so what's up oh awesome thank you
um so I if it's okay I I'll give a bit
of context first because otherwise my
question makes no sense um so um
essentially uh through my whole working
life um I've been really well known for
working well over my contracted hours um
I've been in my current workplace for 3
years um my managers have really
recognized that uh that I work far too
long um and they really really tried to
encourage me to change that um which
I've really resisted um till recently
but I have um since just before
Christmas really tried hard to pull my
hours
back and um I'm suddenly experiencing a
lot of um anxiety um to the point of um
extremely embarrassing uh I'm having
panic attacks at
work and um so I'm in the process of
finding a counselor and um I'm working
on my self-care routine as well but I'm
wondering if you had any other
advice and ultimately I need to sort of
communicate all of this to my colleagues
um and my managers um that I'm really
really trying um but yeah I don't really
know what I'm doing I'm so proud of you
what you're talking about is the curse
of the western world
and it sounds like your body reached a
place that mine reached about it was
about 10 years ago when my body said hey
I've been trying to get your attention
for so
long I
quit right because if I don't quit yeah
I'm hoping it doesn't quit well it's
it's it's it basically like one of your
tires is falling off that's what a panic
attack is that's when your body's like
oh you're not getting this message so
we're just going to start shutting the
system down
right yeah so uh
um man this would be you would be
somebody who I'd love just to go have a
drink with and sit for a couple hours
because my guess is you've got a long
story it's it's pretty it's pretty
remarkable is that
fair um I don't know I talk about work a
lot so I probably bore you to tears okay
so let me let me just cut to it what
does um work is your drug and so my
friend you've heard heard me say this if
you ever listen to the show my friend in
Simkins he lives right down the street
here uh he says
if busyness is your drug rest will feel
like
stress so you've put your entire
identity into work hours in production
even to the point that now it's you were
that fun kid at the bar who everyone
loved having around because you would
always have one or two drinks too many
and you were hilarious you do the funny
thing you would just go kiss the dude at
the bar like you were the fun friend and
now your friends are like hey dude you
got to slow down
that's your bosses do you realize what a
crazy thing when your boss is like hey
you gotta quit
working no boss says that
right no it's a standing joke so what
what
is what is work allowing you to hide
from in your
life that's a very good
question that I wish I had a a solid
answer for I don't really
uh I don't really know and and I'm aware
that's something that I probably need to
to kind of I think you do I think you do
I think you don't want to say it what is
your body trying to protect you from is
it going home to an empty house is it
loneliness are you married do you have
kids uh I have a partner no kids uh
Foster cat um so uh going home to the
Foster
cat um my partner when he when he's home
cuz he works weird shifts
[Music]
um yeah here's what here's what working
a lot did for me I didn't know how to be
a husband I didn't know what I was doing
in the first four or five years I was
married I just got a clear message I was
doing it wrong and I didn't know what to
do and I opened up my toolkit to try to
fix quote unquote fix my marriage and
there was just a hammer in there that's
it I mean I didn't know what to
do and but one thing I did know how to
do is go
work and so I took extra jobs and extra
shifts and then I got a pad on the
back initially and then I got some extra
money in my account
initially and then my wife could do some
cooler things and it felt
right yeah I I don't I you saying saying
that I I you don't um you uh
didn't know how to be a a husband I I I
don't know how to be a a person who goes
home or a person who stops working um I
just so I like to be
occupied yeah but but what is your body
so terrified from did you grow up with
scarcity growing up did you have food
insecurity growing
up uh food and security um very um very
fortunate very aware of my privilege
okay did did um was achievement the way
that your dad patted you on the head or
your mom or did you come up in a really
safe wonderful
environment often without meaning to
very high achieving very um well-meaning
parents really do a dance when they're
Straight A's they really do a dance when
um there's more money being
made that's really
interesting because over time and by the
way this isn't a moral failure this gets
encoded in your nervous system your body
begins to understand through biochemical
processes that the way to connection the
way to love those that are most
important to me when you're a kid it's
the adults in your
life is achievement
busyness earning money getting grades
getting into the right schools getting
the right marks
that's interest I remember something my
dad said to me
that um I got exam results through and
I'd got like 98 out of 100 and his
response was what happened to the other
two oh man we're more similar than you
think Sophie uh my dad and him and I
have laughed about this um I got one B I
think it was my first semester in
college maybe my second semester in
college I got one B I was so ex I was I
was thrilled right cuz that was kind of
a mess actually my first semester of
college I don't think I did great second
semester I was like dude I this is
school and I'm smarter than this I gotta
I got to put some effort into this and I
got all A's of one b and my dad's first
response was huh would have killed you
to just get one
more and I remember that like that
deflated feeling and he wasn't meaning
that at all I think he was completely
kidding
but he didn't have the tools to go hey
you've turned this thing around I'm
proud of you you didn't have that his
dad didn't do that and his my dad my
granddad's dad died when he was 10 so he
didn't have that skill set
right but I I learned early on oh you
will
achieve yeah it's interesting even my
parents are like you work ridiculous
hours and you should really like of
course try to leave the
office so um you've heard me talk about
anxiety a lot it's essentially everyone
yeah yeah everyone who cares about you
is watching you
die and there's something inside of you
that is so terrified of being alone with
Sophie that you will do anything even up
into death to avoid dealing with Sophie
or dealing is probably dramatic just
being
with
your body has identified Stillness a cup
of tea in the
morning just asking your partner to to
take the morning off and let's just go
for a walk even though it's pitch black
outside your body has put a GPS pin in
that that says danger danger danger
danger we got to stay
working and I'm telling you the only way
through that is to go directly into that
anxiety there's not another path you
can't go around it and self-care routine
kind of things that is just Band-Aids on
top of
it it just is
okay anyone who's like well you should
just have a warm cup of tea and take a
hot bath just walk away from them this
is deeper than that this is encoded in
you oh no no no no no no no no when when
i' say like self-care routine I'm
meaning making sure that I go for a walk
at lunchtime get some fresh air
okay but it's it's way bigger than that
which in itself is which in itself is
tortous it leaving my D but but I'm
talking it's bigger than
that this is you saying
um I will only work eight hours today
and I will put a thing on my computer
that shuts my computer off at the end of
eight
hours and I'm going to feel so
anxious I'm not going to know what to do
with my hands I'm not my body's going to
go
and I'm going to head directly into that
feeling not flip the computer back up
work my way around that software program
and then get back to
it my phones will go off at 6 PM period
I will not turn them back on period and
I'm going to feel that sense of
powerlessness I'm going to own
it and only then can you ask yourself
what do I actually want to do right
now cuz here's my problem and you
probably experienced this too I love
working I like
it yeah like I actually like it and you
have to think of it like
alcohol like it's okay to like having a
drink it's okay to like having
two then it will kill
you see what I'm
saying yeah I think so but I don't think
you want to please tell me tell me tell
me I'm so curious because I know that
you know what are you scared
of I think you know what is
it don't know
who say it it's like I don't know
sorry don't be sorry at all this is hard
stuff it's like I don't know who I'm
going home to
yeah is your partner
safe mostly yeah that means no that's a
really bad that's a really bad answer no
it's not it's an ohuh no you can't walk
back now you already said like it's a
truthful answer it's not a bad
answer you can't be mostly safe because
that means you're not
safe and now it makes perfect sense to
me while your body has said you will go
to work and you will stay at work you
will keep working and then you will keep
working on top of
that and your bosses are like oh my gosh
so if you go home and your parents are
like honey go
home and your body's saying we
can't
are you going to love Sophie enough to
go be
safe s right I'm trying to order the
words in my head this no don't don't
just speak just
speak
[Applause]
I don't think I realized till you asked
the question I know it's
scary I want you
to do something you probably haven't
done in a long
time and instead of fighting your body
fighting that need to go work finding
that need to not be in your home I want
you to flip the whole
script put your hand in your chest and
ask yourself this question what if my
body's
right what if the safest place for me on
planet Earth is at a work environment
where God what amazing bosses you have
they're even caring about you outside of
here they care about your mental and
physical health and wellbeing there's
not a lot of bosses on planet Earth that
act like
that that's very true that is very true
you still have Mom and Dad that ah man
they probably man if if if they could do
it over of course they would change some
things but they still care about their
baby
girl and then you go home to a
dragon you know if he's goingon to be as
sleeping dragon or if there's gonna be
everything's gonna be on fire
so here's the deal I'm not going to put
you on the spot because I know this is
hard and if you've never thought about
this before it can be really
overwhelming inside your body I'm GNA
ask please please call somebody today
and go get in and go see
somebody and in your situation I don't
really care what the cost is because
you're not safe
physically okay
fair but I'm gonna tell you it sounds to
me like your body's working
perfectly and in a strange way than God
it's chosen
work as the Avenue of safety over some
sort of substance over some sort
of um thrill seeking
behavior and I'm going to say this too I
don't know that your colleagues at work
need to know the insights of all of
what's going on in your life maybe
they're safe enough and you can tell
them but if you're an abusive situation
you've got to go find a place for your
body to be safe and you if you ever
listen to The Show for more than two
episodes you know I don't ever tell
people to end a relationship get out I'm
telling you get
out if he's not safe get
out it's the only way your body is going
to let you
breathe we love you Sophie we're here
anytime you want to call reach out
anytime any resources we got for you
whether it's Financial uh support or
whether it is uh through the The Total
Money Makeover stuff and financial peace
or it's any of the books anything we can
do to help you let me know we got
you I think it's time to ask yourself
where can I go and be
safe God I know this is
hard you deserve to be
safe we'll be right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six day choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
del. all right we are back man Kelly
Today's Show got heavy heavy heavy it
did real fast real fast on some things I
wasn't expecting yeah that based on what
the email we got in we're like oh okay
no big deal yeah when I y'all y'all send
me like a little scratch like hey it's
going to be kind of about about this and
yeah man hey
and again I want to reiterate this to
all the
listeners just ask yourself what if my
body's
right take the anxiety test we'll link
to it in the show notes here if you take
the anxiety test um and it says like
most of your life is read it did that to
me after I released the book on building
a non-anxious life I took my own anxiety
test and it was like was like five out
of six were red and I was like ah yeah
there we go and it was right it was 100%
right I'd quit doing a lot of things so
get back on the horse get back on the
horse get back on the horse but ask
yourself what if my body's right what if
my body's right all right as we wrap up
the show Kelly you said you found
something on the Internet I did I found
this story last night and I thought it
was just kind of neat so I wanted to
read it real quick a woman um posted
I'll read most of it I'll paraphrase
some of it she said I want to tell a
story when I was in the third grade I
went with my mom while she dropped off
some drugs anyway she sent some some guy
left me in the car and sent some guy out
to quote unquote watch me and it's just
me and this guy he looks over and says
you don't know what a high coup is do
you and I responded yeah it's a Japanese
poem consisting of three lines in a
pattern of 575 I remember I had just
written one in class he freaked out and
told me I was the smartest person he'd
ever met I was
eight anyway on that day he vowed to
make sure I made it to school my own
mother was in her own world doing and
dealing drugs and I tell you this guy
made sure I made it to school every day
he picked me up every day and then did
homework with me who he took me to all
the important things in my life he
became my family the closest thing to a
father figure I had ever known he was my
best friend he saved my life and so
she's telling this because the night
that she wrote this she got a call that
he had passed away he' had a heart
attack so she says anyway he's gone and
I'm probably going to be weird for a
while I'm sorry in advance I just need
to put this out there uh um she said she
she she goes on to thank him and tell
him she said thank you for teaching me
how to change Tire replace my brakes
watch every episode of The Simpsons with
me and literally saved my life countless
times this is what he told me and this
is the important part right here you can
literally or you can have a good life in
spite of your mom or you can have a bad
one because of her and I thought that
was such an interesting quote right
there because we talk about people all
the time the lady in the second call for
instance who has his family history but
you can do it in spite of them or a good
one or have a bad one because of them
and I thought that was very very
powerful yes and that because is a much
more eloquent way of what I try to tell
people set the backpack down like you
can keep carrying that sucker and get
your knees and hips replaced or you can
just set it down and it sounds so
trivial but dude and by the way
everybody
listening when you feel like we're
entering into an election season and you
feel completely powerless and the Middle
East is setting off more and more and
more and more and it looks like this
one's going to Cascade into a big one
and you feel
powerless there's a little kid on your
block that needs someone just to show
up there's a little kid on your block
that needs someone just to throw a
football there's your own kids in your
house that need you to be an adult
there's a school that needs volunteering
there's an extra shift you can grab at
work because a single mom that you work
with needs to be at home with there are
ways to serve everywhere right yeah and
like this girl right here in particular
she is a doctor um and she went through
med school yeah so think about had this
guy not come out think about what her
life could have been her mother was
dealing and doing drugs but because of
this one guy came out and asked her a
stupid question about a
haikou and then showed up yeah just kept
up made sure that her life was different
how one person I mean he changed her
life and now all the countless patience
and family she's impacted because that
one dude out of a drug house right came
out and said she needs better she let's
just call out the other important thing
learn what a Haik coup is people 575 pay
attention to I Amic pentameter these are
important things no one's ever asked me
in a dark alley what the uh square root
of a triangle is it could happen and you
could end up in med
school parents show this part of the
show to your kids only this part but
show this part to your kids kids you
never know when mom's gonna be dropping
off drugs and a guy's gonna get in your
car and ask you a hard question and it's
going to change the course of your
life so here's the other weird question
how'd you get your daughter to write
this question in
Kelly no too soon I ruined a beautiful
story didn't I you did you had I went
too far all right I'm going to retract
that statement I'm going to self-edit
I'm going to slap it up flip it and
reverse it every and thanks for that
Kelly that was a beautiful story yep
sure that was awesome love you guys
[Music]
bye